foreign
that's how she told you
pretty much yeah and then yeah
she said don't freak out and and so I
did and here I am I'm calling you
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney's show
so grateful that you are here with me
and the Gang and the greatest
podcast in the history of the world when
it comes to mental health and parenting
and relationships and marriage all that
stuff it's the best ever
can you already tell we're so glad
you're here hey if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k and for those of you who've
been ride or die since day one right
um
so so grateful for you please if you if
you find some value in the show a no
cost way of helping out it'll cost you
anything if you will leave a five-star
review if you will forward an episode
that means something to you to a friend
or to a family member or to your
mother-in-law if you don't want her to
call you anymore
um send share these episodes subscribe
do all you know all that stuff works but
it just helps get the show in front of
more people and it's such you guys are
such a gift thank you so so much uh
let's go out to Alex in Sellersburg
Indiana what's up Alex
Hey Brother John how are you partying
man what are you up to
oh I'm just hanging out making horse
noises buzzing or uh blaring some Little
Drummer Boy and having a good time
well you obviously have a much better
producer running your life than I have
running mine because I have had all
those things taken away from me so good
for you Alex
just kidding I'll relay that to the wife
let her know Kelly likes my wife took
away Drummer Boy which thank God she did
because I hate that song and Kelly took
away my horse noises so I'm glad you're
in a better position Alex thanks for
kicking me while I'm down so what's up
hey to be honest I I'm not a giant fan a
little drummer boy shout at you you know
who is nobody and serial killers that's
who all right so what's up
so I guess the the short answer or
question is uh uh how do I be a better
dad
um it was a couple of weeks ago laying
in bed like I said just hanging out and
the wife rolls in and says hey who's got
two thumbs and is pregnant and Uh I that
said well not me and so uh that's how
she told you
pretty much yeah and then yeah
hey well good morning Alex that's
incredible get some coffee that is
incredible hey at least you didn't go
get whiskey you went and got coffee
you're already off to a good start man
um she said don't freak out and and so I
did and here I am I'm calling you
I didn't know where to turn so I called
the podcast guy
um man so you you haven't had an
opportunity to be a bad dad yet so what
do you what are you stressing about what
are you worried about
or what about this whole this whole
thing freaks you out
actually number two okay uh baby number
two
um and he's
a few weeks away from
April okay
um and I guess uh every and so are we
all the cried out method think about
that
um I I've heard that's that's bad don't
do that but I've also never been told
okay well don't you know throw the doors
open guns are blazing at every time you
hear him whimper
um so I'm and things like that just uh
you know uh spend time with them well
how much time I try to spend as much as
I can and then uh you know and then when
in discipline uh he's in this uh our
baby number one is in this throwing
phase and you know he just the other day
through something and and broke a a
glass something or other I can't
remember I think it was a candle or
something and I I uh okay well don't
spank them don't but they tell them no
and so I sit here and and wrestle with
all these uh all these aspects whether
it be the cry it out or the the uh
discipline or spending time and I feel
like it's like I'm swinging far one way
as in
um you know every time I hear him cry or
you know just a little bit in bed I want
to come running in or I swing back far
the other way where okay well let's give
it let's say 10 minutes 15 minutes yeah
and and like I don't
um I don't have a good I guess uh
straight line path to follow as if there
is one
um so you know I guess I'm looking for
any advice still even as a dad of a
two-year-old and a soon infant I just
feel like I'm like I said I'm I'm all
over the place yeah
um
I don't know if this is this will mean
anything to you but
um
you're in a very common place for dads
of two-year-olds
like there just comes this moment when
you're like what am I doing
you know what I mean like yeah I I like
you said I I want this I want there to
be
a set of Ikea instructions I don't care
how complicated it is I'll figure it out
and I just need to put this thing
together
and then somebody sends you a podcast
that says well don't do this and then
somebody gives you a book that says
don't do that and then you just snap in
the moment and default to something that
your dad did that you had promised you
weren't gonna do right and it's just I
it's just a failure Factory and by the
way two-year-olds are two-year-olds and
so they can be the best at snuggling up
and they can rip your heart out
right oh yeah
and it doesn't also help that your wife
probably looks like she knows exactly
what she's doing
she works with a lot more kids than I do
and so you just end up and so I I'll
walk through it with you and then I'll
Circle back here's where
many many many men including myself find
himself
baby number one
about this time
and you just start feeling like I am
more in the way that I'm helping
anything
and every time I try a thing my wife's
like God why just do it like this
because she's been babysitting since she
was six and nobody would trust me with
their kid when I was in Middle School or
high school and or fill in the blank
there's just every little thing
and so when I started I'll just speak
about me I started leaning a little bit
more towards you know the one thing I'm
good at is my job I'm good at that I
could at least go do that and I'll make
money for the family
and so I just kind of turned the wheel
two degrees
and I ended up way far away from my
family
so you're in a moment kind of like a
boxer is when he keeps getting tagged
from the outside
the Temptation is to back up a little
bit further away
when the best strategy is to bite down
on your mouthpiece and leaning in and
get closer
okay so let me tell you this you're not
going to quote unquote figure this out
because as soon as you figure it out
your second kid is going to be so
radically different than from your first
one you are gonna you're gonna feel like
you got half the Ikea thing built and
then they shipped you another set of
instructions that's completely that says
something totally different
and so the best thing you can quote
unquote figure out
is you
who am I gonna be when I get frustrated
am I gonna let a two-year-old or a
five-year-old or a 16 year old dictate
my emotional regulation
when I find myself getting overwhelmed
and frustrated which happens to all of
us it still happens to me regularly and
I do this for a living
what am I gonna do am I gonna yell am I
gonna throw a temper tantrum am I going
to tell my wife hey I need to take 10
and go outside
am I just gonna grab a trash so I can
start emptying the trash in a huff like
some dads do like what do you what who
are you gonna be
all right right yeah and my dad was the
the the Yeller and the slamming of the
door right my dad and I'm certainly not
bad but I find myself saying like let it
go back to the thing he threw and broke
the candle or whatever like I I was
sitting here thinking what about what do
I do and I just get sick I get so tied
up and thinking about what to do how to
respond to where it's like I did nothing
and the next time he does it you know
I've been I start thinking oh God this
is just a behavior and this is how that
screwed him up he's just gonna be this
defiant little baby and uh well I had my
chance I blew it or you know on the
laying in bed crying oh that was five
minutes too long
I've screwed them up and and he's gonna
have emotional problems for the rest of
his life and you know so like I said it
just kind of freeze and and what to do
and I
I don't know
so I guess think this way what I'm going
to say is going to sound so cheesy okay
but here's what I want you to lean into
I like cheese I do too man I love it I
love it
um
respond in love
here's what that means
when my baby cries now when they're
older I've got you know my kids are
older I can and you'll be able to tell
in short order like this is a real cry
this is not a cry this is a fussy cry
this is I'm frustrated cry this is I
need somebody or I'm scared cry
there's times when the most loving thing
you can do is to hold your two-year-old
accountable in an appropriate an
age-appropriate two-year-old way
right he's not gonna want to be a kid
who's throwing and breaking things
he feels wild and out of control he
doesn't like that it's discomforting he
needs a parent to set boundaries he
doesn't need a parent to come and swing
it at him
he doesn't depend coming in to scare him
to death by screaming at him
but he does need to learn hey if you
choose this then you also choose this
whatever that consequence happens to be
Okay so it's but all of that you see how
calm I am because I'm not giving a
two-year-old my I if I leave stuff on
the ground that a two-year-old can
destroy and it's going to be devastating
to me that's my fault because I'm the
adult
so I've gotta change how my house looks
and I gotta move stuff so that he can't
have things that he can break and
two-year-olds will figure it out
I saw my daughter climbing up the
cabinets the other like a spider and I
was like I don't even know what to say
to you right now I don't I don't have
any what are you doing literally what
are you doing
um she's trying to get a knife off I
mean it was just like what okay right so
the most important thing in that moment
is all right was it been four minutes or
six minutes no no no no
that's not gonna mess your kid up
and I I even hesitate to say this out
loud if you're thinking about
quote-unquote messing your kid up it's a
parent that is immobilize himself with
anxiety with tension because they don't
know how to respond in love see what I'm
saying
okay yeah and so I want you to spend the
bulk of your time
if you feel like you need to get up and
go hug your kid and it's been 30 seconds
instead of the agreed upon four minutes
get up and go hug your kid because you
know
okay
you're not gonna mess your kid up and if
your kid cries it out for a few minutes
longer than you you're not gonna mess
your kid up
and you there will come a moment if you
come from a yelling house when you snap
it'll happen
you're not gonna mess your kid up
especially if you take a knee and you
look them in the eye and you say I'm
sorry you get dead on their level and
say I absolutely blew that and I as your
dad I'm sorry
see what I mean because you're gonna
mess up a lot and they're gonna go to
see a counselor someday and be like and
then my dad did this and you're gonna be
like yeah I did that
right who are two or three men just name
them their first names
that have a kid who's seven or 10 or 14.
that you can regularly call and or go
get coffee with go grab a drink with or
whatever
uh
exactly that's your yeah that's your
mission
okay
uh no one but I don't want his advice
but
I got those friends too who I love and
if it's wartime I'm calling them dad
advice not so much I'm good I'm good
yeah exactly yeah yeah I want you to
instead of trying to find another blog
to read about the I want you to get two
or three men that you absolutely trust
and you see there the fruit beared out
in their kids
okay and I've got several people in my
life who's raised their kids very very
differently one's homeschooled one's
public school one is very very very very
wealthy one is not wealthy at all one is
right in the middle
but their kids are funny
and I like being around their kids
and their kids are super respectful and
kind and their kids work hard and some
of their kids get D's and C's but
they're busting their butt and some of
their kids get straight A's and they're
busting like you see what I'm saying
like I want to ask those men those women
hey how what's the next right move here
that's where I'm gonna Garner a lot of
my wisdom okay but you see what I'm
saying you're spending the majority of
your energy
on who am I gonna be when my kid fills
in the blank like does whatever
right yeah yeah I think I'd do a good
job of being like firm
um as in uh like well actually just
yesterday yesterday evening
um he likes suckers so if we sit down
and you know watch TV for a second he
can have a sucker but he got up and kept
running and so no sir I'm running with
the sucker in your mouth when you're two
so you know I lost a sucker man I can't
hold still uh and I felt horrible about
it but I also you know I had this vision
of a two-year-old ball with a sucker
yeah that's cool that's cool keeping
your kid from dying it's one of that's
that's yeah that's dad 101 right or yeah
and stuff like that and then I think
we'll shoot was there something maybe
something else I could have done nope
nope nope the kind of stuff I get I mean
I just go down those rabbit holes and
and things like that and like oh well we
watched YouTube video of tractors he
loves tractors and I say oh he's seen a
phone and a smartphone and no we know
what smartphones do and you know that
those are the kinds of things that I run
down and I guess I just get caught up in
the paralysis of the analysis yeah and
sit down I mean I've got all kinds of
books of half-read you don't need any
more data brother you need some
relationships
all right
you know how to be a good dad don't let
your two-year-old run with a sucker in
his mouth
sure yeah you know what I mean and I
want you to
consciously practice now
practice right now when you take that
sucker away and he gets those big tears
in his eyes or he lays on the floor and
kicks and screams and you ignore him
and you feel awful feel that fully don't
run from that
because that is what Dad feels like
and when your two-year-old Wells up and
cries because you took away something to
keep him safe
or you took away something because he
made a choice and there was some as
consequences on the back end of that
that turns into when your kid is seven
and you say Hey you give me a hug before
school and he goes no dad I don't like
hugging you
hey dude that hurts right
or when they're 17 and they sit down and
they say Dad I fill in the blank with
whatever a life-altering decision they
made
right so start right now feeling oh
sometimes dad feels uncompanying a dad
feels uncomfortable I gotta do hard
stuff I gotta tell my kid no and I hate
telling my kid no I gotta tell my kid
you made a choice and here's the here's
the consequence to that choice
right and for everybody listening don't
think I'm um like I do have I I very
much have a a research oriented like
response to cried out method and I've
got very much research oriented
responses to spanking and all I've got
opinions on all those things
and if we want to go down those rabbit
holes I'm happy to do that but
Alex is like most of us we have an
analysis of paralysis I like the way he
said that we over analyze everything and
we keep seeking more data more data more
data more data more data more data
instead of more relationships
and if you just text somebody while
you're sitting there if you've got three
or four guys that you trust three or
four women that you trust and you can
just text them and say hey
my kid is a rashed it looks like this
and they'll all respond all cool simple
no problem
whew that's gonna go to the ER hey guys
my two-year-old just ran with a took off
running with a lollipop in his mouth and
I took it out
and he just started crying really hard
am I a terrible Dad no you're a great
dad all right cool we're just practicing
we're just learning new stuff
so focus on the relationship Parts
you'll get the other things right you'll
get some of them wrong and that's all
right and that's why you want friends
that can push back on you
um and man I'm happy to work through
individual situations if you call
but the bigger picture is the tension
and the anxiety I'm I'm usually outside
of abusive situations I'm more worried
about that with the kids than I am
whether it was two minutes or seven
minutes or five minutes or I swatted his
hand or I I'm way more worried about
does your kid feel electrified in your
presence or do you feel warm and safe to
your kid let's focus on that which means
we're not fixing the kid
we're fixing us
it has a way harder proposition we'll be
right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back
um this is pretty rad I haven't had this
happen yet on the show uh Julia gulia
returns like one week later so I'm gonna
bring her on hey Julia what's up
hey Dr John thank you so much for having
me back of course okay so for everybody
listening
uh it's probably a week or two ago Julia
called in and so your son your you have
a whole history of family stuff but you
are going to see your sons
step family and for Christmas in like
South Dakota or something yeah a little
bit Norther than that okay
somewhere where it's cold and Barren and
sad and yes yeah we're going there and
he didn't want to go because he's 17.
and he has a sweet little girlfriend and
he has a new job and so we talked about
what do we do we make him go not make
him go all that okay and then right
Kelly this just now said hey I have a
surprise Julia talked to him did all the
things you said deloney and now she
wants to talk to you again and I can't I
don't even know really what's this is
gonna be awesome okay so what's up oh
man okay so yes I took your advice and
honestly for the first time or one of
the very I was like an account on my
hand just a handful of times I have
stuck to my guns with my son I felt good
about what I was asking I felt solid
like yes I am being rational
um I I told them you don't get to vote
but do you get input like you said and
um I said you know we'll go work out and
we'll do some things that you've enjoy
too and I felt really confident and I
didn't even second guess myself how did
it go really good
you know it didn't really go that great
yes he he definitely pushed back which I
was expecting
um he did it did soften the blow
somewhat when I took your advice and
gave him some control over how we spend
our time there so that did help
but it did not really go well he um we
kind of thought about it but again I
just said you know what you don't get a
vote you don't get a vote I just kept
repeating that and
um and a couple couple days went by and
I'd been asking him to take the time off
of work for those few days for several
weeks before we even spoke hoping that
he would and a couple days go by after
we had the talk and he told me that he
was unsuccessful getting the time off
work because he didn't ask early enough
oh what a great Flex hey right you
raised a very smart young man well
played like on tipping line he
definitely did
I just I yeah I was uh half mortified
half like wow that's impressive so um if
it honestly if that had been my kiddo to
high five dim like well played
uh you know and I I've been really
thinking oh I know and I've been
thinking a lot about all of this and
um you know I I don't remember I know we
talked about a lot but I raised him as a
single mom and I really my entire or his
entire life I've had a hard time telling
him no
because I just thought I brought this
child into the world with no without two
parents and early on I decided that I
was going to try to give him everything
he wanted in spite of that and I think I
really messed up I really do I I don't
and so I've always given into him and um
at this point I don't really know how to
differentiate between
normal teenage boy behavior and
and my own expectations if they're
normal if they're rational
and then we have this other history of
me really having a hard time saying no
to him because
that's just where I'm at and
here we are yeah so I
sounds like he's he's received a vote
he's got to vote his whole life
so this is this is a
this is something he doesn't have the
maybe not even have the psychological
wiring for
right I know damn I know that's okay
it's all right he's gonna face us at
some point and it's better that he face
it from you than his first boss or from
a college professor that fails him
because he you know whatever right um
and so he's gonna he's it's the the Day
of Reckoning is coming
um okay in or actually it's here
um and you've got you've got Glimpse
number one so you know and I think I
don't remember if I told you this
there's no chance that talk goes well
in terms of I think it goes well and you
said what you need to say you said it in
a way you just say it it doesn't go well
where he leans back and he goes gee mom
you're right
your job is to raise a great man and
that means you have to say no sometimes
you're right it went to no man me and
girlfriend have already figured out how
she's gonna sneak over to the house
while you're gone and I'm gonna make all
this money and so it was just a a
complete
his plans blew up and they never blew up
because he gets to decide everything
that happens in his life so here he is
um and so I'm gonna think through this
out loud is that cool
absolutely yes yeah
um
here's Avenue number one
is this the hill you want to die on
is this and what I mean by that is he's
gonna have to learn this
is this the one
um or
is there another one like I don't I
don't know what the next step is is he a
senior in high school or a junior
he's a junior so I'll still have a year
I'm at home okay that actually actually
makes a difference
um
foreign
right now
right or do you if you back off of this
one because you're pretty Resolute this
time
if you back off of this one does he go
exactly like always I think right right
she kind of drew a line in the sand and
he just smiled at you and stepped across
it
and uh
the second one is I don't think where
does he work
he works at Chick-fil-A yeah I don't
think they'll fire him I really don't
especially if he walked in and said
um
I absolutely blew it I was supposed to
take time off to go be with a family
situation that I didn't want to be a
part of and I messed up but I have to go
on this thing and I really value this
job
right I agree with you yeah I don't
think they will fire him they might
because they have to but I've just done
some work behind closed doors with that
company for a couple years and they are
of the highest caliber of Integrity
especially when a young when it comes to
raising young people
um the third option is which this is
kind of the nuclear option is you tell
him I'll go with you
and I will sit with you when you tell
your supervisor or your lead manager
whatever they call them there that you
didn't take the time off this is a
non-negotiable trip and that you hope
they don't fire him but you understand
if they have to let him go
right
and you will look like the word he he
again he's going to look at you not out
of anger he's it will be bewilderment he
doesn't know you no he doesn't you know
I mean I know I know
um and so
he's a hundred percent age appropriate
there's not one thing he's doing that
makes me like oh no
um he's never had a boundary and you put
one up and of course he's gonna run into
it and see if it falls down see if
there's a way around it'll wait over it
can't go under it right he's that's his
that's his job he's 17.
right
um
what you have to be prepared for is he
goes to war
right
I don't know how to I don't know how to
do that I don't
um but I definitely feel Resolute in
this
um because I feel like if I don't do it
now
like you mentioned before he's gonna
face it some other time or I'm not going
to be there to help him and to counsel
him and it's going to come from left you
know from from Left Field
um and I feel like I've already wasted
or spent a lot of his youth not helping
him with this skill have you told him
what you just told me
I haven't no I think that's a good
conversation to have
and he's not he's not going to
understand it but he'll hear it
okay he'll think it's just I mean part
of him it you'll be a Charlie Brown's
teacher
yes and part of it is hey the world's
Coming For You at a thousand miles an
hour and you don't even realize it yet
and because I loved you so much and I
didn't want you to hurt so bad I
protected you from a lot more than I
probably should have and I'm not going
to apologize for it because a it's over
and B I did it out of love even though I
did it I would probably do it
differently this time
all I can control is what happens next
but when I say go to war
it wouldn't surprise me if you came into
like my office at the local University
and you came in and
he starts doing drugs
he sneaks out
he runs away and just and goes to his
girlfriend's house to try to avoid going
on this trip like it none of that would
would be shocking Behavior to me
okay that's good to know okay I mean
it's you still gotta you still may have
to call the police to go find him you
still may have to get a coach or another
Mentor that that is in his life that can
help out but not any response he has to
these boundaries
um isn't going to surprise me
I I would default as best I can and
again I talk too much you listen to the
show you know that
um I I err on the side of over
explaining
okay
I can do that and it may be as simple as
man
I will help you when we get back I'm
gonna help you find another job if they
fire you I'll help you okay right you
know what I mean and that's kind of just
like a weird what like but I'll I'll
help you
um and I'm happy to go up there and do
it but I think the right thing for you
to do is to go let your supervisor know
that you you
forgot to ask off or you didn't ask off
soon enough and you blew it but this
family trip was mandatory
right and it's again it's a hard hard
lesson it's a hard lesson
um
but if this is one you want to stick to
on your stick to your guns on
um
man I mean you got you got my support in
my vote
thank you I don't want there to be an
illusion that it's going to be like all
right you got me
I you know I don't I don't think yeah no
I'm I don't think for a moment that's
how it's gonna go
um I keep wishing for that
but uh yeah I I've been through enough
now
um
but this time I'm not giving in I'm not
I can't for his benefit I can't keep
telling myself that yeah this is for his
benefit and
just with your help and I'm confident in
sticking with this and you know I
believe it's going to go okay I do so
and maybe at the end the way out of the
gate is
um put two or three or four nice
restaurants
on the table and say where which one do
you want you get to pick where we go
tonight
okay because and you can tell them we're
gonna have Mom and we're gonna have mom
talk number two and he'll roll his eyes
and be like rolling big roll them big or
even set it up beforehand hey I want you
to go ahead before I even say anything I
want you to roll your eyes as much as
you can do it do it do it perfect and
make him do it and do it with him and
then say Hey you get to pick two or
three restaurants because we're going on
Mom and son Talk number two and I'm
already telling you you're not gonna
like it it's just part of being my son
and you know what I'm saying like it was
just gonna set the stage but also we're
quietly kind of through the side door
we're giving him some choice
and he can choose to go talk to his
supervisor he can choose to have you go
with him he can choose to quit but he
doesn't have to choose whether he goes
on a trip or not
okay I like I like it is that fair
it is fair and can I say one more thing
you say anything you want
well
I just want to let you let you know that
I complete completely agree with you
bro is the best Rock ballad ever yes
hey I'm gonna I don't want you to say
your kid's name on here listen young man
your mom's brilliant
she's very smart listen to her
you just enjoy yourself on you Julie you
just made my whole my whole week isn't
that song incredible I get goosebumps
amazing I used to push play alone in my
room and just stare up at the ceiling
and listen to it over and over
and it still rocks to this day I mean
and when I heard you say that I
literally had to rewind the podcast I
was like wait what listen everybody yeah
Skid Row I Remember You I want you to
get in your car put your headphones on
get in a quiet private place and listen
to that song alone and if you don't
start crying you don't have a soul ah so
good Julia you are the best of the day
the
best
this will be hard
I wish I could tell you it's going to be
not hard it's going to be simple moving
forward it's gonna be really challenging
one last thing I would recommend Julia
you have one or two women that you trust
that you can reach out to when you're
about to cave in
you have one or two or three men that
you trust that your son trusts that you
can reach out to that they can go to
coffee they can talk they can go to
Cracker Barrel Waffle House whatever
um go for a walk or a hike or a run that
he can just complain about you and be
like she's just all of a sudden and they
can say yeah you're exactly right your
mom's um overnight the light came on
she's seeing a fuller picture of your
life and
um
world's coming at you real real fast
and Mom is no longer going to be able to
stand in the way
he is lucky lucky lucky to have you and
um you're an inspiration to all of us
parents who have realized we need to
make some changes and these changes are
gonna be real real hard
and the adult thing to do is to make the
hard changes anyway
we'll be right back
all right we are back let's go to Sarah
in the warmest place in the U.S
Fairbanks Alaska what's up I think
that's where oats Military Academy is
what's up Sarah
hi Dr John how are you good that was my
uh Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
reference for those of you who weren't
paying attention so what's up
hey yeah so I'm just going to start with
my question
um how do I support my husband and focus
on repairing our marriage when he is
constantly worried about his health
tell me more
does he have cancer or does he have like
hormone disruption like does he have
health issues or
what's going on
no he doesn't have cancer
um oh no okay oh man I could hear it oh
honey you are real real real close to
resenting him is he like a is he is he
like a
is he like that guy on Sleepless in
Seattle
uh an ailment or a thing or his knee
hurts or he's going for a walk with the
kids and he's got to put like an ankle
brace on and he always has like I think
I've got a thing and he goes to the ER a
lot
yeah
I could hear that in your exhale
yeah I mean I I don't I don't I wouldn't
say you know he'd like goes to instead
of putting like ankle braces on and such
but
um
I I would say that uh
I mean
I would think so yes
okay give me an example
oh
hi
that he thinks his his gallbladder you
know is giving out or
um you know he'll Google like the
silliest things like if there's a red
mark on his hand he'll Google it because
he won't be sure if it's something
serious or not gotcha okay
gotcha
um how long have you been his mom
probably too long yeah
and it's weird trying to sleep with your
son huh
yeah and I mean that in all of the
awkward gross ways it just sounded when
I said it the whole thing right as soon
as you start getting in a caretaker role
and then you become like a you're fine
honey and he's like am I fine and there
gets this awkward Dynamic then the last
thing on earth is intimacy and sexual
desire and that turns into his anxiety
things spinning faster
which in his case creates more
well what about this and my my fingers
hurt and then all of a sudden
I mean you see how like y'all getting
this dance now and it just it y'all end
up you're like all right I'm done
so can I ask you a real real hard
question
yeah
um
is there somebody else for you
um
I don't know I mean you do
or maybe it's not all the way there yet
but almost or man it would be nice if
it would be nice if yeah that's all you
have to say I won't push you on that
anymore
um I
and again I'm going back to that single
exhale I could hear it
like you're you're at the end
or let me see this one
you have put a lot of this on him
you don't like who you have become
um
um yes and no
um I know this is all him
I mean no no I definitely like owned to
my mistakes
um 100 but I do I just feel like
um we've only been married for going on
almost four years so I feel like
majority of the time we haven't really
been in a happy marriage
yeah so that's sad to say
um yeah I feel like there's been more
stressful times than happy times
what's what's the root of the of the the
unhappiness
um
I know you've thought about it because
you've had imaginary conversations with
him that you've never said out loud like
you've you at least in your guts believe
this all starts at a place where is that
place what is it
I don't
I don't know I feel like there's just
two there's too much I feel like that's
gone wrong it's like what's gonna go
right
I
I asked him the other day and he he told
me that he thought that
um my parents were the reason that
our marriage is so bad are they
partially
why do you allow that
the setting boundaries okay
have you wanted to set boundaries
between the
uh
have I wanted to yeah
yeah absolutely let me say it this way
do you want to get closer to him
yeah
do you like the way things are right now
what's stopping you from making them
different you're you're an adult in the
United States you can kind of do
whatever you want except for like
shrooms and stuff
right what do you want to do
and when I say like you don't like who
you're becoming here's what I mean not
that you've said mean things and haven't
done bad hey you know haven't put
boundaries out whatever
you had a picture of yourself
and you had a picture of your marriage
like a woman that got was taken care of
or that was super sexy or you were
married with a guy and you'd go do crazy
fun things
and he would punch the guy at the bar
who was mouthing off to his wife and I'm
just making up crap right but you had a
picture of what this looked like
and now you got kids
yeah how old
uh two and one oh good God Almighty so
okay so you've been married four in an
unhappy marriage and you got two
toddlers which are just incredible for
your sex life and you are now
a
woman who goes to work
and you have your uh somebody else makes
your heart beat a little bit faster
you're an exhausted mother of two really
you're an exhausted mother of three
and your husband's way of getting
attention from you
his way of finding meaning in your
marriage and your partnership is
something's wrong with me that I need
you to help
or I need you to feel sorry for me
that's his entry point with you
and that's what I mean you just don't
like who this the you in this
yeah I would agree with that fear
yeah for sure
so what do you do next
um well
we're in the process of moving for for a
start
um
and is also
working on
getting better health care
for himself
nope
um timeout
what are you going to do
uh
uh let me put it away are you done well
one one are you done go ahead are you
done with the with not with me with with
the marriage are you finished so if
we're finished let's just be finished
no
do you want to stay married and build a
life for this guy
yes
do you want him to be your husband to be
the father of your kids he already is
the father of your kids but do you want
to create a tightly woven together
new picture with this dude
yeah absolutely
you just saying that
no okay
then we're going to start by we're going
to stop judging him okay it's a waste of
time it doesn't help
when's the last time you sat down and
looked at him and said your needs out
loud very very clearly
I have no idea
let's start there because at the end of
the day that's all you can control
you can't control whether he feels a
lump on the side of his leg or if he's
got a weird mole that he feels like he's
got to go to the ER about you can't
control any of that
you can control how honest you are with
him yeah
and you can control your needs
hey I need this from you
and I need you to go get some
to go see a counselor because we've gone
to the ER a bunch we've gone to the
doctor a bunch and none of the things
that have happened so far have proven to
be uh life-threatening or even medical
ailments and so I'm concerned there's
something else going on and I'm happy to
go with you
and if you don't want to go that's fine
I'm gonna go for me
because I want to learn how to love you
better and right now I'm not doing a
great job
mm-hmm
see what I'm saying and those are hard
conversations
foreign yeah yeah absolutely
okay what are you thinking
you're shutting down on me don't shut
down
uh I don't know it's just
it's a lot
um
although I mean he hasn't been diagnosed
with anxiety but I do feel like he does
have really bad anxiety and I don't
as you just described him that's that's
what it sounds like
what do you mean
he sounds like a guy with a ton of
anxiety
and having been one of those myself and
having had some really really
uncomfortable conversations with my wife
over the years being married to somebody
who has deep and profound anxiety is
Madness
it's exhausting
and you ultimately have to create a
world that only you and your kids
inhabit because your partner's
electrified it's like being married to a
taser it's not safe
and you didn't get married to have to
build a life on your own inside of a
cocoon
you also didn't get married to be a
third to have a third kid
who's in an adult body
so I'm I'm I'm I'm
understanding having done what he has
done done to you I've done that to my
wife so I get it it's awful
and the only way he heals is through
connection that's not to put the burden
on you he's gonna have to reach out and
decide he wants to go get well
but you can't make him do that
you can only say this is what you need
because he knows you don't like him
yeah yeah
he knows that
in his body's way of dealing with the
fact that his wife doesn't like him is
to create pains here or Phantom things
here or whatever
you see what I'm saying
yeah
I feel like we have had a lot of hard
conversations okay
um
typically they don't
sometimes I go somewhere sometimes I
don't but
I think you need some action steps at
the end because he's probably talked
about your parents a bunch and you
haven't done anything about it
yeah that's fair to say
I think well one I think moving will
help
um
don't don't forget though that doesn't
the moment well no it's just a moment
you're moving to that new house and you
get all the furniture down and the kids
go to bed
you're going to look over on the couch
and he's going to have two kleenexes
shoved up each nostril and have a
heating pad on his neck and you're gonna
realize he went with you and you went
with you
right yeah so moving might help
proximity wise but it's not going to
solve your marriage issues because those
are going to go with you
yeah no I agree with that and if you've
had a bunch of hard conversations most
of the time I talk to folks they've not
had these conversations
if you've had them what y'all are in
desperate need is of is is action you'll
have to start acting differently
yeah I mean that's the hardest part it
is
and the only person's actions on the
planet you can control are yours so you
have to start acting different
call a counselor go to the gym
get a couple of women in your life that
you're friends with call your parents
and say we are not coming to the holiday
whatever or y'all are not welcome at
fill in the blank I don't know what the
boundaries that's probably a whole other
phone call
um
if he asks you to come look at some
weird mole or what you can respond I
don't have the medical expertise to do
that but we do have a mobile
physician and you should call them
I'm asking you I need you to not go to
Google anymore because Google
um is like putting gasoline on this fire
in our home and you just find a thousand
different so I'd rather you talk to a
medical professional and since we have
Telehealth
um you can do that right so I need you
to
put all the screens down and just sit
with me and hold my hand and watch a
show
in the evening
I need you to put all the screens down
and just rub my shoulders in the evening
and I'll say this
um
don't cheat
don't cheat on him
[Music]
I'll leave it at that just don't
stump
you're worth more than that don't do
that
I think she'll call and I know it's
you're stuck you feel like you're frozen
in ice and
somebody's got to take the first step
even if you sit down and write yourself
a letter and say Here's what I'm going
to be moving forward
but I want to be somebody that I respect
and that I treat with dignity and that
means I gotta act differently
and that starts today
[Music]
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show in
honor of the great Julia gulia
I know we did this did this recently
but it's the song that makes my heart
beat a little bit faster
it makes me love a little bit more
songs well I remember you by the great
Skid Row
Dave the snake Sabo and Rachel Bolin
that's so great
woke up to the sound of pouring rain the
wind would whisper and I'd think of you
I think if you
and all the tears you cried they called
my name and when you needed me I came
through
and paint a picture of the days gone by
When Love went blind and you would make
me see I'd stare a lifetime into your
eyes
so that I knew that you were there for
me time after time you were there for me
remember yesterday walking hand in hand
love letters in the sand I remember you
and through the sleepless nights through
every endless day I want to hear you say
I remember you
oh my gosh listen to that song right now
and be prepared for pound chickawa one
hey we'll see you soon party on
[Music]